-Now, Burger King
is making huge cultural strides
in Finland,
AKA Discount Sweden,
neither of which is Norway.
-Okay. -But we couldn't
resist this pun.
Reservations
for the spa are currently $285,
while here in America, people
are getting high cholesterol
and clogged arteries
for under five bucks.
Diners can have their Whoppers
and fries served to them
while they relax in the spa,
'cause nothing makes people
hungrier than the thought
of eating meat in a hot room
with sweaty seniors
with their balls out.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Now, at normal...
"Those are not tater tots."
Now...
-(laughter)
"But they're on the ground."
"I know. I'm old."
-(applause)
-Now...
At normal spas, you can get
massages and facial scrubs,
so, comedians, what are some
services offered
at this BK Spa?
Sinbad.
You get a free massage with
that really creepy king dude,
but you get it your way,
and you like it.
-All right. All right.
-(laughter)
-Points. Points. -Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
-Uh-huh.
-Brandon.
Chicken fingers come
two in the barbecue sauce,
-one in the stink.
-All right. Points.
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
I...
I would guess it's excessively
stink after that meal.
-Yeah.
-Uh, Moshe Kasher.
Uh, the Whopper is a 7-foot tall
Viking named Hans.
All right, points.
-Points. Perfect.
-(applause)
SINBAD: I'm not saying anything,
but he didn't even
-buzz in.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Uh...
-I... Listen, I don't... I don't
-have to buzz in, okay?
-Wait a minute.
I don't even have to buzz in
when I call 911.
I just say, "Hello. I need
help," and they're there.
-(laughter)
-It's amazing.
(applause)
JOHNSON:
I still
don't understand why you
color-coded the stage?
HARDWICK:
I didn't color-code it.
Oh, it's a gradient.
(laughter)
-Yeah.
It's all right.
It goes from white, darker,
darker, and then Chris.
-Uh-uh, uh-uh. No, I am not...
-(laughter)
I am not black.
I'm dark white.
(laughter)